all right and we
are live the last word returns
with lord cognito andy bontis fresh at
that friday morning campfire
it's been a while you we're back we got
do we got anything special going on oh
man we got we have a real
real life man joining us today um but
yeah we're just gonna get into it right
here
so everybody here we go let's do it
welcome to the last word episode 122.
it's cool chris friday morning and the
campfire is burning
morning beverages are in hand shameless
plug
and once again we're here to talk about
destiny we are off for a week so we're
back
today we have a man who started playing
games on computers older than most of
our listeners so gaming runs deep in his
veins
you want to know what else runs deep in
this man's vein film movies
tv all things cinema and the silver
screen he went to school to learn about
it so he definitely knows
he's helped make movies both behind the
camera and also in front of it with
stunt work in huge movies like the
amazing spider-man
daredevil teenage mutant ninja turtles
in case his time on the silver screen
wasn't awesome enough he's also likely
spent plenty of time on your phone or
computer screens showing you what it
would like to be a guardian
in this day and age in real life this
man has cast supers
he's done finishers and is well versed
in all ways of the guardian movements
this man is out here doing in real life
what most of us only could pretend to do
with a controller in our hands
so let us introduce a man after my own
heart with a love of gaming and film
that rivals some of the best in the
business
a destiny one beta veteran who's downed
atheon and also visited the lighthouse
and while xbox may have taken taken him
to the console places he knows pc is the
true master race
irl guardian welcome to the campfire how
you doing sir
yeah can i say what an intro let's go
the way you just constructed that okay
hello how are you doing
you're allowed take it all in and take
it all in back on topic
we got to celebrate you man you have to
can't fire you guys
you're in here you're one of the trio
today we got the three musketeers this
morning
and i mean could it be better we got a
guy who's a guardian in real life so
who else can talk destiny with i'm
honored to be here thank you
awesome how you how you been what's been
going on with you
well i i'm sure many people out there
have been like where
where is he where is he yes
uh and also because we were doing this
today i wanted to
um share a new video that i had
uh kind of kind of in the bank so i put
that out before we started
yeah recording just so everyone can um
have something but uh yeah i taken some
time off to step back from you know
uh content cr creation and even uh
destiny 2 as a whole
and sometimes you just got to do it
sometimes you know
as much as you love the game uh the game
and you know
the content you're making sometimes it
pays off to
know take a step back and focus on other
things
absolutely absolutely i'm just letting
the chat know
uh that that video that you put out i
believe the uh
what was it bulwark hurl finisher
finisher put that link direct link to
your twitter and and the actual
move that itself in it so people can
know what you're talking about
but yes this this is cool this is really
cool i love
when you do that stuff so let's actually
start from the end like as far as like
you know just gaming and i know we'll
get to destiny but just gaming in
general like what got you into that
oh like as what
said like older than most man yeah
an apple 2 desktop computer
and uh i played
things like gauntlet a lot of people
know what gauntlet is a game called
uh arkanoid uh which has been remade
like
hundreds and thousands of times and then
uh there was an actual
uh floppy disk aliens game
and i don't remember too much of that i
just remember being in the like the
cargo loader and fighting the
the the big uh mother alien uh and then
from there i moved
you know onto like windows platform uh
pc gaming i played a [ __ ] ton of like
doom and doom 2. and uh i was a big fan
of
a game called dune 2 which is based on
the frank herbert uh
novel and i just
i just love shooters you know even from
back then and i played
um a hell of a lot of
unreal tournament which i loved i
still crossed my fingers that you know
someone out there is going to like
remake
it you know classic classic crazy yeah
crazy arena shooter
um and then
uh super close to my cousin and he had
og
xbox so he played uh halo and halo 2
like endlessly together did you what did
you do the land party with the halo 1
did you just do that how many tvs in one
house
did you had to eat that cable running on
the floor uh with the legs
honestly i never i never got crazy into
that
because i i i think mostly we just play
we just played co-op like we just played
like yeah we just did
uh split screen a lot and uh maybe like
he had a friend come over like bring his
xbox and we we did like maybe two tvs
but
that was about it that's that's a star
official yeah
that's multiple screens exactly yeah
what's another tv entered the robe
you're an official halo now like
you did that i was the crazy person
taking like my dell
19-inch like this thing weighed more
than i did
giant like crt monitor like lugging that
thing to my friend's house in my car
setting it up on like this there's a
card table just like shaking in its legs
because this monitor is so heavy
i did that stupid stuff so that's all
good
you knew it was worth it though i did
want to give a shout out by the way to
zoe thank you for the raid this morning
sending the love over here and all of
you guys in chat thank you for joining
us so much love
thank you very much if you guys are new
uh we got irl guardian if you guys have
seen him on twitter
i would be surprised if you haven't
honestly so we'll be here chatting all
morning so if you're new to the show
welcome yeah welcome exactly salutes
always everybody shout out to
holly bond in the building and she says
he's listening on his drive to work give
you that more yeah
mod by the way if you guys enjoy the
focus beverages go there use code ar
3s this man gets you 10 off of that
focus beverage gotta give him a shout
out as well
so when you're in the morning you gotta
get focused gotta get focused
that's what's up man but yeah you got
some stuff for uh
oh yeah no i was going through like your
history games and stuff like unreal
tournament like that was
doom three i mean roller coaster tycoon
i love how you got a mix though
like you got shooters for sure but
you've also got like dune
um you've got i got some weird ones in
there too like i was like what else you
got what are some oddball games that
don't fit like everybody's like shooters
and you're like
roller coaster tech and i'm like thank
you there we go a mix i like it
roller coaster tycoon like uh rts is
like
dune 2000 which is obviously there's
like a follow-up to dune too
uh and man have you guys ever heard of a
game called slave zero
i have not put us on what that was about
so
you're basically it's like saying that
way distant future it's a
third person um i guess the third person
shooter uh and
similar to like halo like you can only
hold like two weapons and you have like
a third
like shoulder rocket thing you're this
giant robot you're walking around like
basically [ __ ] blade runner city
and you're able to like like you're just
like running
on highways crushing cars while shooting
like you know either helicopters or
other giant robots
it's wild i i love the [ __ ] out of that
game and then there's another game
um called revolt which is
one of my favorite racers of all time
it's basically
just like um it's just like you know
chris team racing or
mario kart where you know there's
there's pickups and
uh you know power weapons
yeah yeah but you're an rc car and
you're driving around like either a toy
store or a neighborhood or
you know just really different and cool
themed
uh racetracks and there was always like
you know a secret shortcut
it's just those are type those are the
type of like
you know racing games i [ __ ] love the
[ __ ] out of it yeah that's cool
man that's cool man i like i like the
way it sounds like the concept of it too
so yeah
cool so yeah man you did that you know
what i'm saying you've been gaming for a
while and
then you moved to the 360. you know
yeah it was 360.
yeah um yeah
what came with it was gears of war and
halo 3.
you were sad
midnight release for halo 3. that was
awesome ooh
shout out to those midnight releases
being on that line with that
anticipation
for your favorite game hey we've got
midday releases now in the middle of
covid so
[Laughter]
yes
that you can try and hope to be awake at
the right moment for stand in front of
the right store or click on the website
at the right moment because yeah
yeah all the stuff's been a little
little difficult to get a hold of um
that's awesome uh so i know like you got
a little history with
bungie there with halo 3. um what was
i knows like for you what coming from
like
shooters and rts's and such the variety
of background i don't see a whole lot of
like rpgs per se or anything of that
like leveling type nature
oh wait i forgot to mention that yeah i
played
the original deus ex oh nice one
nice and when i was playing it i was
like i don't know what this is about but
i look like neo from the matrix and i
dig that
and then and i went back and i actually
finished the game i was like yo this
is awesome and that kind of like further
um inspired me to get like the
i didn't get like the direct sequels but
i got human revolution and then like the
i got the
two latest ones um
trying to think any other rpgs but yeah
no i i was never like a final fantasy
kid i think i i bought lois odyssey
on 360. uh there's something about it
that just didn't like
catch me yeah it's a long haul game i
just
i was too young and hyper for it you
know
the add was real you're saying that
it's real guys you know take care of
yourselves out there i hear you brother
i hate you man
that's cool that's cool and uh yeah like
i said we've seen the halo we see that
stuff
so then uh this uh little game comes out
this
uh this destiny thing right right yeah
under the radar yeah it's no game now
i've been playing almost 6 years
the next thing from bungie hits the
stage what is this
so yeah let's talk about it man like
what what really
you know lured in what was the appeal
for you
you know for you to be passionate and
somewhat synonymous with
destiny i
i think it was just the trailer came out
and like
you know the wording in there was like
creators of halo i was like i'm in
doesn't
[Music]
how much i would have got hooked to it
like i was just expecting like another
shooter
i think no one really expected what
vision
bungie had for what they were trying to
do and um
succeeded with with uh destiny and
destiny 2.
and man me and my cousin were day one
you know
betas guys i would delete the character
just to grind to level eight you know
multiple times
i did that yeah because like ever
because you could only go so far with
the beta i was like man
like it just felt good to like level up
and like
you know get that get that notification
ui notification or something yeah yeah
man destiny destiny one is a special
game
it's it's tough to capture that that
whole
you know lifetime of that game yeah
yeah absolutely absolutely that's what's
up guys you gotta i'll let you go yeah i
was gonna say yeah i was like i gotta
ask because like obviously
we're gonna talk about destiny we got
plenty of that stuff but man i have a
wall
of movies upstairs and i've been a movie
man forever so
sam um like as soon as i could actually
the first computer i bought that had a
blu-ray drive was the first one in my
house and i was like i had the first
blu-ray movies in my house
and they were all in my room and i was
like a couple in my first three and one
of them was trash it was like deep blue
sea but
but everyone is a good movie oh like the
first one's not bad like say
like samuel jackson is a nice little
model like oh but that's a whole
different story samuel jackson ll cool
jay's the chef
yeah yep yeah and he's got this bird and
everything uh
yeah i'm trying to remember the guy in
it
but yeah it's like it's got it's i don't
know it was just wonderful you said the
right people everyone else doesn't
matter
yeah yeah and then like so it's like
i've i've been collecting movies since i
have like 500 upstairs or more of like
blu-rays and dvds
collecting forever and stuff so when i
was like to see that you're like
you're in you make some and stuff like
how where did your passion for like film
and movies and everything start
like where did that begin um definitely
super early when i was a kid
uh my dad was always into movies
uh he
he shared you know with me at an early
age like the original star wars trilogy
terminator terminator 2 i think i
watched the matrix when it came out
and i like it in 99 i just like that's
my all-time favorite movie
or argue one of the greatest movies ever
made
oh we're here i mean you're gonna talk
that's what's up
right there let's go but chapter 2
chapter 26 on the dvd for the lobby
fight scene or something like that i
think oh man
man i had i have the ultimate matrix
you know dvd box set i've watched all of
that
extra content yes animatronics
enter the matrix video game path of neo
video game
i i yo i had max payne one
for the pc and pc was the only version
that
was shipped with a mod software attached
to it
and people went off on this thing and
made
a matrix game basically in
max max payne's engine like you would
boot this thing up and like they would
even have like the loading
screen like make sure it's code like
rolling down your screen like
people went all out you know in these
mods and like
that was probably the first makeshift
game like i ever played
before into the matrix um but uh
but yeah like as far as like my love for
movies yeah
my my dad got me in uh super early and
we just we'd rent movies all the time
from the library when that was a thing
and uh we had a huge library of like vhs
um tapes shout out to vhs
yeah vhs where you had to put it in an
actual
rewind machine yeah yes yeah
yeah man i just i adored like things
like star wars and
uh jurassic park
like just those big blocks buster movies
that just
really just to this day it really does
anything like that just like that you
know spiked
inspiration and you know imagination
like i was all for nice
nice listen man i'm loving what i'm
hearing definitely
as far as the movie selection as well so
with that
you know kind of your dad opening up
that that chapter and stuff like
you know would you say that kind of
influenced you in that direction now
as far as i want to get into film like
what was that transition or was it
more of a martial large thing like what
was that trend as far as stunts and what
you do
you know how did that how did that
cultivate so it's pretty interesting so
uh
again early on when i was younger
uh i also loved legos and so lego
came out with a set that was
you know like in partnership or like
whatever you know
endorsed by steven spielberg um
and uh it came with like a stop-motion
camera and it was like a set that was
like designed to look like a movie set
with a backdrop i had like a t-rex or
whatever
so and it came with software
uh to edit you know stop animation um
what do i where where towards the rest
was this yeah
it's like i did like please it was
called lego studios please if you're
quick on google look it up um wow this
sounds cool keep talking
and so i started making like my own stop
animation
um movies or films
uh with legos and i think i mentioned
uh in the thing you sent me last night i
ate
and this also proves how much i love the
matrix i legit
remade the matrix lobby scene oh boy oh
boy in lego like the
lego stop motion uh
the the uh
quality is like dookie at this point but
it it was like something where i would
like run to my parents room like play it
on my vhs so like okay that's
that's what it looks like that's what
happens to the run back to the computer
and
and like make it happen like keep
referencing it over and over it took me
i forgot how long it took me but uh
man it was just awesome to like make
something like that and it's so
cool yeah let it go
you're doing that and then like so from
there i was like
oh like this is fun it's cool like you
know i can
and make you know films like with legos
but then i i saw the shortcomings of it
it's like man like i wish it you know
legos
lego you know minifigs can move in a
certain way i was like let me
you know try to do some live action
stuff and
uh to my best friends at the time uh
i think they had already made
or like would record things um
and i didn't know about i was like oh
cool like you know
and i think just together we started
making like a bunch of things like
during like middle school and high
school
and then uh from there uh
one of those guys uh had plans to go to
film school and so did i
just to be you know a filmmaker and be
in the industry
and then from there uh halfway through
my college
time i started working on films um
he's like a production assistant and i
knew i wanted to be a storyteller of
some
of some degree um but i obviously knew
it wasn't an
easy road to to go down um
all the while i was studying
uh japanese jiu jitsu as a hobby
just because i love that and um
did karate earlier as a kid so i also
had like you know an
interest in martial arts um
and and then it wasn't until i worked on
uh michael bay's ninja turtles
that that i put together that i put
together like oh wait like
i already do martial arts and these guys
are like kicking ass doing stunts it was
like
maybe i can you know combine these two
um and from there you know i just kind
of make connections and
uh join the screen actors guild
um and started to
kind of like hustle myself out there to
be a stunt uh
performer and
then yeah
and then from there i just been i've
been keeping at it
that's awesome brother like um just to
hear that
you know that's actually a a pretty
dramatic shift too because you kind of
you know you went from like all right
i'm gonna make films you know say i got
with that aspect but then you always had
that passion
and you were you were a practitioner of
martial arts and stuff like that so
that's actually an interesting chance
and then i i like the smooth
you know ninja turtle drop that was that
was kind of smooth right you dropped
that in right there i
i'm gonna let that rock but it was cool
i like that i like that but yeah man
like that is so
cool that that switch and um you know as
a person who appreciates
you know martial arts and that stuff you
know it it's really
you know cool to see you know and um
this glass before i give it to ease like
so from uh jumping in like
what i this i feel like this like i've
talked to a couple of guys that you know
i do stunt and i feel like
you guys are so under appreciated
there's so many
aspects of it that people don't
understand the hard work
how you guys push your bodies the things
you're willing to push yourself
through that's the biggest thing yeah
right so
just to add on you know like
tell us about that because this is not
easy
man it is not easy uh
it's not it's i think it it takes a
certain mindset to
to do it you know it it seems fun from
uh an outside perspective but
you know it's it's it is dangerous
in some regard but it's also safely
dangerous or it's like
you know calculated risks as a
sometimes what we say about it um
yeah it's i mean you you hit it on the
head too
you know we just we put ourselves
through
a lot more than people are aware of and
you know we
train a lot more than people are aware
of
um yeah it's not an easy task
i was like four i was gonna say for like
the stuff that you've been through are
there any ones where
somebody presented you like a stunt and
you're like i
have questions like like you're like i
mean
there can be like wire work there can be
other things but it's like there's some
you're just like
i got i got a couple things because i
don't want to die like
i have have been ones that take you to
that level or you've gotten quite to
that point yet that's a good question
yeah sometimes because it it it's
it's funny to think about it like that
because it's like okay you're gonna do
this it's like just like a
you know a wild comment and and it's
like just left with like crickets and
silence and like whatever you
like your thoughts come up with but it's
usually as part of it's usually a part
of a
um a conversation and
uh i've done some some wild wire work
and
uh gone through glass and uh
you know did fight scenes while a barn
is like
burning down around me um
but uh i know it's it's just
it's usually presented in a way on an
even
uh playing field where it's like okay
you know
we're this is what's gonna happen and
it's it's also
i wouldn't i wouldn't be in the position
to hear that unless
you know my higher up felt
i was prepared for it right so most of
the time
uh i am you know willing and able in a
position
but there's always there's always
someone's like oh that wasn't what i
thought it was
this wasn't in the cadre i wasn't aware
of this one
yeah yeah i didn't see this in the
ledger
but uh yeah mostly there isn't like a
you know uh any sort of like curve balls
which is it which is good probably good
for you yeah
on the flip side has there been a
situation
you know i just want to get like
stuntman culture right so have you been
in a situation where
if a stunt guy or yourself refuses right
does that kind of like put you into this
like
negative space where it's like he's you
know he's like oh well he's that guy
we will go look for guys um
i hear what you're saying yeah it's just
um um
some have an old older mindset and
people you know think that you should
just say yes to everything it's
right it you know you at the end of the
day
like you still have to go home you still
have to like go to sleep or
you know you have to walk away like you
know
you if you feel that you know something
is unsafe
you should be able to say no and i
i know people have said no and sometimes
they get [ __ ] for it but
also some people that don't say no and
you know like recently a bunch of my
friends who were
also some people were you know we look
at videos of like
you know uh gnarly wrecks in like movies
or whatnot
and you know some of us have been
present for like rehearsals of that
and just hearing like the direction
taken for
you know some of that like oh we want to
like see this fall like super nasty it's
like
okay like you know we see the one that
like
was before that note it's like damn that
that had to hurt and then you see the
one
where they're like no make it nastier
and then
that performer gets hurt it's like it's
like
it's like i was like okay you're like
what were you looking for
we're like like um or
you know like was it in a position where
you could have
like talked it out and you know tried to
protect yourself before
it it was taken like a bit too far um
yeah the culture is the culture can
sometimes be a bit um
harsh in that manner because you're
surrounded by people that would be like
yeah okay i'll do that yeah okay i'll go
over here yeah yep
that's what i was thinking i mean like
those are going to say tying video games
together there's
i mean there's a debate floating around
right now about a certain like company
right now of
like choices that they make and it's one
of those where
people always like company what company
trying
um but generally it's just like there
are certain jobs be like
oh like just like oh man it's got to be
amazing to be in that role and it's like
while it is very cool as you're saying
it's like there are certain points where
it's
you still got to take care of yourself
and you hopefully
even though they may be like hey there
may be 10 people right behind you who
wants your job if you're not willing to
do it
they'll do it for less and riskier or
whatever it may be
and that's like that's kind of a tough
mentality especially in yours when your
body's at risk you're like
you may get tired or worn out working in
some other jobs but here you're like
you're like
i'm in a risky like triple flip car
wreck things like i don't know if i'm
gonna come out of that one i'm not
entirely
and that's and that's kind of it kind of
sucks that you have to but that's some
of the mentality sometimes and
it's i mean it's good to hear that both
sides exist i guess to where you're like
some people
do like support like the you know make
it a discussion for both people involved
and some people are like
maybe a bit more old school i guess it's
just kind of a shame it's still there
yeah yeah it's just you know it's just
the
the experience everyone brings to the
table in
a collaborative industry um you know
it's bound to happen and everyone's not
gonna be
you know on the same same mindset uh
especially
of how much you know our voices do play
a factor in our
our creative minds like you know you
know
people i work for i i have also been in
a position where you know i can
kind of change
you know an outcome or you know being
you know somewhat of a charge of you
know
performers and an actor and you know
make it safe or make an eye you know oh
nice i didn't know you had that input oh
that's also
yeah pretty awesome yeah man i mean um
this is tremendous stuff and i love to
hear
you know as far as your journey and
stuff like that and just in this
industry it's very fascinating to me
you know i mean i think that it's a it's
a cool story and also as well as like
again pre appreciating all the detail
the behind the scenes stuff that you
guys put in
you know because i know dan well i i
can't do it
so you know i wanted to salute you on
that man that is so cool i wanted to
transition as far as just another aspect
of it which is
the games industry you know and um we
know now
as games get more sophisticated things
improve and stuff like that
you know i want to shout out uh a
gentleman we've had i've had on iron
with
eric jacobs and he's been doing that
kind of stuff and
he's been he he was a game he wanted to
get in as a stunt guy he wanted to get
into the game industry
and what i noticed is um salute to him
because he i think he got the uh
god of war he was able to to do the
fight scenes for uh
you know so yeah oh you're familiar i
don't know if you're familiar with a
button oh yeah yeah
uh he's uh okay i
i think i met him one time at comic con
but but yeah he i was i don't think i i
think i was trying to get into stunts at
that point
um but uh he was very short i
didn't have a lot of words with him but
yeah he's he's done uh
incredible work for the gaming industry
and he's definitely someone i
i look to uh as far as like inspiration
oh yeah salute to eric man good guy very
cool um but i wanted to transition as
far as like
the gaming aspect because as you see
like we've seen these games
crazy mocap studios all this oh yeah
right is that a lane that you would
consider or be interesting if the
opportunity presented itself
uh oh yeah of course and i i've it it's
a funny
it's a funny part of you know i guess a
stunt
bubble uh no that's not the way i want
to say it
it's you know the motion capture is a
space for you know actors and performers
and stunt people to
to work in an interactive media field so
it it's
it's if you think like you know being a
stunt person
is a hard job like mocap is like kind of
the tear above that wow it's a very
niche um
part and it this isn't me saying like
it's you know anything bad about it i
just think it's the way
the way it's kind of developed it just
has become very niche or very uh
closed off because they don't need any
sort they don't need
um a lot of your likeness right
um except your body frame
and i've also been fortunate enough to
to do some motion capture it's just
sometimes it's tough to talk about
because the ndas are like super
uh super strict but um oh yeah stick
stick with those don't don't run
respect respect yeah
yeah i worked on a game that already
like came out uh like a year or so ago
but
um i don't even know like i don't even
know as far as i contract if i could
talk about it
i mean some of that stuff is probably
meant to be like hey there's actors in
certain places but we need you for this
just don't tell anybody and you're like
all right i'm still getting paid
yeah yeah uh it's it's funny because
like i
you know i would play a character in
that you could probably see it on my
imdb actually
so it's not that big of a secret um but
you know i'd play a character and then i
would play you know the player and then
those devs would talk to me like okay we
want to do it
you know if the player approaches this
interaction from this angle or
you know we have to kind of cover like
all the angles that
um that would happen and uh
it's just it it's wildly different work
because it's interactive gotcha
yeah i mean i guess you could imagine
for certain things like how many takes
do you need to cover things from
different angles or whatever because in
as you said like a film is like shot
it's on screen you get one like
once the director has that chosen look
of how they want they're done like as
you said if it's interactive there's so
many more variables that go into all
that stuff i would guess
yeah and there's less to hide behind too
like when you when you move
like they're they're capturing all of
that data
and you know the way you move is the way
you move like if you
you know like if you walk like pigeon
toed like they're gonna see that
but you wouldn't see that on screen you
know right and
you know not that they they bash people
for like things like that but
you kind of have to like really like
sell
sell the type of character you are
right to another degree that you know
on screen uh film and tv um
is a little more like lenient or like
you can cheat it a little bit
um but it it's also incredible work like
i i also love doing motion capture
because just
video games are amazing to be any sort
of part of
yeah i mean i guess i would imagine i
mean you go through difference of
performance and you go
on screen even if you're not the main
they're still
you're a body doing a certain thing and
even if you go to mocap you're like
the only way you can even sell yourself
in doing that is like
do i have the right body mechanics
because that's what you're selling you
have like
you have a wireframe skeleton that a
program is capturing and that's all
you get to sell you don't even have like
you know the swiftness of your movement
like they can tweak all that stuff you
just have to have the right skeleton
work and you're just like that's kind of
hard to do
yeah yeah no that's for sure i
i think it's even more so like the yeah
they can tweak
they can tweak some things in the data
and the way you move or like you know
where they gotta stitch uh animations
together
right but uh
sometimes it does help to like you know
be
to perform in a way where it makes less
work for the
devs right i'm sure they love that
absolutely absolutely yeah yeah
yeah so let me ask you though another
thing i want to ask you is uh
being that my nickname is the ninja i
have an appreciation for
martial arts and things of that nature
so yo man like i just went like as far
as like
martial arts films or just in general
like the stuff that you do
you know you know i see out there doing
the the hunter supers and the movements
and
everything is looking authentic like so
like
my thing is as far as the appreciation
for the martial arts as far as stun
stunts and film and stuff like that you
know like how is that how is that
working in the industry and stuff like
that and
just like interacting with people on
that level
uh as far as martial arts i mean it it's
awesome
to to talk to other people about martial
arts and the you know it's a culture in
itself
you know
are you familiar with nazca yeah so
um
since we're like older very old you know
we can make fun of we can make fun of
nasca a little bit because nascar's like
you know
you're hyped up on red bull doing your
bo staff kata in front of judges
screaming your head off that is like you
know
um but yeah we everyone has like an
appreciation for martial arts and comes
with a different background whether it
be you know
wushu wrestling or even just
professional sports
uh it's it's all it's all just so
welcoming and brotherly or and sisterly
um
that you know different disciplines can
still like come together in one format
and you know
do their do their skill set nice
collaboratively it's it's amazing
that's awesome man it's it's so cool
like i said i i just feel like it's
you know it's a beautiful art and in
just all the different martial arts and
and just to see
that replicated in film and stunts and
stuff like that like again so much of an
appreciation for you guys
you know that that continue to kind of
keep the torch alive with this kind of
stuff because you don't see it no more i
mean
you know i'm older you know so i grew up
in those days you know it was the big
you know blockbuster star and you know
the martial arts was very
more in in tune and ingrained in film
culture and um
you don't see it as much anymore now i
mean you know everything is i guess
just i just maybe it's an industry shift
and stuff like that but
i just missed those days like i grew up
with like watching the old 70s
kung fu flicks and the bad dogs
i'm from that era so whenever i see
someone whether it's in stunt film any
aspect video game
doing martial arts i always have an
appreciation for you guys so i wanted to
toluca i thought that was pretty pretty
very cool about your background
oh thank you man thank you yeah i was
like i wanted to ask like
so like obviously as a stunt man there's
a lot of
actors who don't do their own stunts
hence why you guys are usually doing a
lot for them there's two
that i can think of though um and once
you see them either go through the
training and i'm sure they don't do them
all
or they are crazy enough to do some of
it keanu reeves and tom cruise
like from john wick from doing like gun
gun foo or whatever you want to call
that some of the stuff that you see him
get to do
and then just some of the crazy hanging
on the side of an airplane stuff that
like tom cruise does just from a
stuntman's perspective like
how is it like to watch some of the
actors not like steal your job because
there's still plenty that like
hey it's yeah so it's it's like what is
it
but like what do you see when you see
stuff like that you see like
the main face like tom cruise hanging on
the side of an airplane or some of those
like
are you like he's crazier than i am or
it's like i wish i could be there too
like what are your thoughts when you see
stuff like that i'm just kind of curious
uh
as far as keanu reeves like i i love
guiana rivers um
what he has done with the john wick
series
um has been amazing because that that
kind of skill set
is my background as far as like fighting
um so i relate to it on a very uh
intimate level um and
just his dedication to that role and how
much he trains
especially for what is going to be
four and five that they're gonna shoot
at the same time
um he uh
yeah he's his dedication that
just how his revival in hollywood has
has like such a like a good feeling
um sense about it all it's just yeah i
i mean uh i don't i don't mind him
taking the work or
doing like the fun action like people
are
here to make their actors look uh
the best they can possibly do and then
as far as tom cruise tom cruise
best stunt performer ever like
because he's he's not only an actor he's
doing stunts that you know
people have rehearsed but he's doing it
in a way that you don't have to hide it
on camera
like i don't know if you guys have seen
um the that last clip that came out for
the new mission impossible where
he's like on a dirt bike no no not that
the the the new one that's coming out he
uh
um he like rides a dirt bike into a
gorge and just
like goes off of a giant ramp lets it
drop
and then just rips a parachute out
oh my god he's insane that's the third
yeah
you see that but it's also it's also
like keep in mind that you know someone
had
rehearsed that they had practiced that
they had thought it out they
you know had gone through all the steps
to make that even a thing but
you know sometimes presentation like
sways people
you know you just see tom cruise like
hey like
see you later i'm on this dirt bike now
like flowing down to the colorado river
like see you later
but he because because of his dedication
to
you know his craft like he got a
helicopter's license
he even for the new top gun like you
know
that's him in that wow that
f-18 or whatever you know fighter jet
that is wow
um and that makes
that makes the filmmaker's job so much
easier because they
don't have to put someone that looks
like tom in there
they can make the film a better
experience while
having a camera on his face while he's
doing barrels
at like g-force three you know
playing playing his character you know
it's it makes
it makes the experience better it makes
the
absolutely you know the job user and
we say it all the time like you know tom
cruise is just amazing and
uh not many can do what he can do
uh and i don't feel like he's stealing
you know jobs for me at all
i it's just it's fun to watch i i hope
he does it for a long time and i hope he
doesn't get hurt knock on wood um
and yeah can't wait for the next mission
possible
yeah seriously those are those are
awesome so that's just
even same with uh henry cavill or
in witcher that's him doing that sword
work oh i know yeah
yeah like maybe there's there's
instances that you know
he's taking gnarly rex and he needs to
you know
do a love scene after that he can you
know he
that he can't like hit the ground of
course you know we got to savor
actors for those moments but um he's
doing
he's doing those fight scenes he
dedicated himself he you know he
trained his ass off he worked out for
that role you know
and i think that's a new wave like what
we were saying lord
of hollywood and cinema as far as like
martial arts in action that
that's a wave that's that's been
happening since john wick
to see actors put in the work to take
their performance to the next level and
you know um sorry now i'm going to go
into a different
uh keep it going
devil too all these stories
as far as like uh just martial arts and
cinema
it's it's become it's become a lot more
nuanced it's become a lot more
ingrained where whereas it's not just
like jackie chan doing
you know right that's just doing his
doing his thing against like
owen wilson and like shanghai noon it's
you know
now it's it's someone like you know
chris hemsworth max you know
taking out you know a bunch of like a
bunch of dudes in an apartment you know
for
a netflix film well that was a tough
scene too man
yeah it's so it it's become a lot
less like on the nose and it's like
more into what the process of filmmaking
is and
i guess the the part that shines in
in headlines is like the actors really
like training but
um it it's become less like okay this is
a kung fu movie it's more like okay
there's there's hand to hand fighting
yes
yes yeah i agree i agree i i it's just
so
so cool to see you man i love it to see
all that stuff
captured on the screen shout out to the
to the russo brothers too they do a
fantastic job oh a lot of things oh yeah
stuff i mean just i remember um the
elevator production
oh my god don't get me do it i get
emotional with that scene yeah
the opening with the ship like like
because there's there's times you see
captain america just running around
beating stuff up
that's like one of the times you get to
see him just kind of kick ass
like all on his own truly seeing cap for
his like strength and everything and
then he's got the one on one
and he's like i thought you were more
than the shield he puts on his back he's
like dude let's go and i was like oh
here we go
but yeah the elevator too is like um i
just wanted to ask if
anybody want to get off before we i love
the confidence in that one he's just
like
it's on like donkey kong guys let's go
that's good filmmaking man like a fly s
line and then a
sick fight scene like that this is a
good time all around
even and rest in peace oh chad chadwick
boltzmann
oh my god we did not deserve him dude we
bro such a special
guy right um seriously the thing for me
what really sold it is like i said what
was it the
avengers civil war right prior the end
we get the introduction to chadwick and
the black panther character
and that those fight scenes with him and
bucky
on that and i'm dude i was losing i was
like yo it was so well done and such a
great introduction i actually felt the
fight scenes and that was better than
actually black man
his personal faces but um dude they do
such a
fantastic job and it's one thing to see
like that stuff
on screen replicator so much
authenticity it's very visceral it's
very impactful the way it's shot
like these are important movies to me
you know what i'm saying so i just
love that you also have you know saying
an appreciation for this stuff and
you're involved in this stuff like this
that is so
so cool you know i mean to be on the
movie sets like this
look to you and just being in this
amazing you know film and fighting
martial arts and stuntman culture like
so dope yeah we could fill the entire
podcast with this stuff we also
literally this could be a podcast yeah
about
spider-man and dandelion we got to bring
him back
hey it's your show guys you can ask
whatever you want
best news on break right now it's fine
here we go
we could get through the 12 in like 10
minutes so yeah just bust through it you
know it's fun okay cool yeah we got
stuff we got technology we got weather
yeah okay
now i was going to say like for you last
one for me uh and then we will actually
get to game stuff i'll try
do you these are hard but do you have
at for you do you have any movie like a
favorite fight scene that you like to
watch that isn't in the
[Music]
if it's matrix the matrix fine like
lobby flight scene may take it anyway
but i was just like
no it's all good um or you can say too
if one's in the matrix but yeah
i want to try and go outside of that
fight fight scenes in general or movies
either you can go like top two movies
top two fight scenes yeah just
couple top ones because huge respect for
the whole industry
i re-watched the movie recently i
i love the rarony kitchen movies
oh dope and i'm a
sucker for swords so i
love those fight scenes i am so excited
that they're making
another one because of how successful
they were and they're just amazing
movies in general
they're not you know japan has taken
their
filmmaking to the next level with you
know trying to match
like you know high octane action with
dramatic performances and it's very
very excited to see you know what they
do next with that series um
all three of those movies um and then i
love the raid
um okay the raid [ __ ] kicks ass dude
uh and trying to think oh
uh a movie called iron monkey
yeah the lord knows that movie
is like i forgot how good that movie was
i think i saw that when i was like a kid
and my dad brought it home and then
i watched it again i was like damn these
fight scenes kick
ass sick sick bro yo the chat is
loving you right now chad is like um the
new rad said blade
somebody space cowboy said a hallway and
oh boy
shout out to dakota she's like king six
boy i love that movie
shout out to good girl she's like k-6's
fight scene with the balance in for a
second
salute to the code of acting through
that destiny that's hilarious
yeah the 10-minute fight scene in the
raid
so you get we're seeing ray ray's
getting a lot of love but yeah they're
loving that too
favorite scene in the matrix gotta ask
since that one's in there is it the
lobby
it's the lobby man it's i've watched
that so many times
and then i mean every scene just has
just has the right amount of
of action i even love like the bathroom
fight i just love everything in that
that movie um but
everything just feels awesome because
there's like so much stake
behind it you know like morpheus uh
sacrificing himself to fight agent smith
for the first time
just to get neo out which he doesn't
even know is the one
or not he just believes it's so hard
that he's gonna
headbutt his ass into [ __ ]
for you to have that movie as like one
of your goats
is so dope to me because it's the same
for me and like i said just the um i
know we're going off with you i gotta
throw this in it it i i love you know
morpheus the training scenes right and
getting his mind right to bend reality
like you are bigger than you know i'm
saying like
those transition between the technical
aspect of
you know you're in this it systematic
program
with the martial arts aspect of freeing
your mind
right that combination for me
and just the aesthetics the way this is
filming shot the looking film
it will always go down as one of my goat
films like
always that movie even just the
uh thematically is so
was so ahead of its time yeah like
before even people have thoughts about
what that movie could represent or
you know could relate to so ahead of its
time and
you know any time if anyone has like
my wife just told me like a co-worker of
her of hers just watched it for the
first time
oh she's like she's like adding i i
didn't understand it
it's like of course you did because that
movie that movie
represents um so
like i said like it can mold itself into
so many different things that it's hard
it's hard for it to relate to you just
on first watching
you have to like watch it you know oh
yeah again and again for
you to speak to you yep you catch more
things when you go yeah like
in chat cyber area was like you think
that's air you're breathing when that
sinks in
oh my god like oh my god even the scene
where
he goes to see the oracle and she's like
uh she's like oh by the way don't worry
about the vases like what phase and he
turns and knocks it over it's like
he's like well real if i can doodle in
this if if i didn't say anything we just
still have broken it it's like yo
let me just do it every format i picked
that movie up
i didn't i even have hd dvd when i
thought that was going to win
i got it
every time the matrix is released the
entire set is purchased this oh it's
just re-watched it's just sell you
everything
and i'll even still rent it on like
streaming devices like
you just keep supporting that movie just
like it's just yeah
just keep supporting i can't wait to see
i i'm a little
i'm nervous but hopeful because i heard
the script
is ambitious and deserves to be made
i mean i i think
i was like for keanu reeves to come back
for it after having
a success in john wick and like do those
so
well it's not like i think for him to do
it it's got to be hopefully at least
decent
because right i don't think he would do
it if it was just trash
at least for that yeah that's why i'm
with i'm with ira guarding that because
it's like
it's it's i'm i'm a very like when it's
a masterpiece something's
in my opinion a masterpiece i always am
nervous when people try to revisit
something like that because sometimes i
feel like there's a moment in time
don't touch with my you know don't mess
with my mona lisa leave it alone
yeah like really ridley scott's been
doing that with you know
the alien franchise prometheus and stuff
yeah right
i think i'm not sure i'm not sure what
kind of direction you know he's going
for it
you know it's funny sorry i didn't mean
to cut you off florida no no no no
go for it brother it it's interesting to
see what ridley's doing with the alien
franchise because
it's like it's like maybe you just you
just had coffee with him and coffee was
alien you know and then you know someone
else was like
someone else went off and you know
obviously it was cameron and
um fincher with uh the next two but now
like it's like no i i it's not just
it's just not like that first cup of
coffee i had
which is pretty [ __ ] good so you go
back and you have that cup of coffee and
you know it's prometheus it's like hmm
it's like okay this coffee wasn't as
good or like
now you have like a second cup you know
it's like oh wasn't as good and then
you have alien covenant it's like oh
it's still good coffee but like
you know so it's interesting to see like
when you give
an artist like that more of a voice and
with a
franchise that is so beloved to
audiences like
more time and more um energy it's like
it's just interesting to see where it
goes so like that being said about you
know the matrix franchise
you know um i believe it's lana or what
oh chowski that's doing it not not her
sister
um or maybe
she helped write it uh i don't know the
exact details but i i know only one
wachowski is
uh directing it it's not a duo anymore
um
but i just hope because because it's an
original creator
and they know the property so well and i
i think at this time right i think it's
been a long time coming
that warner brothers has been trying to
push it that there has been a script
idea
floating around that deserves like
that is like a proud um
oh yeah not not a proud thing but like
you know an ambitious
and thoughtful idea because the first
matrix
they wrote that like over 10 years yes
please
you know and what it's 20 20 20 now
and uh
you know revolutions came out in 2003
right so i'm hoping there's there's some
time
in there that was spent with uh
you know writing this story and it gives
new meaning to
the world we live in today as far as
like you know
the themes that go with it escaping from
reality
absolutely like i said we can just hope
you know that they
they they do you know it injustice and
and keep the spirit of the films and
that that the integrity so
you know we we got our fingers crossed
man just hoping to
do this thing because we all cherished
that that that film
well speaking of escaping from reality
we also jump into the world of destiny
every so often
yes that game we play no man like
like we could talk about movies until
now we got them so
um but we were off last week if you guys
um i should put something at the
beginning be like hey if you want to get
to the destiny chat skip ahead
if you want to talk about movies and
stunts first half's in there too
that's like but honestly man it's been
if you don't like it
no it's like honestly it's been a
pleasure having you so
uh i appreciate that thank you believe
me uh but we
even last week since we were off we got
a little bit to catch up on
um to start we had 100 chance of snow
we're gonna have weather systems on
europa that like
change dynamically for just while you're
roaming around on the top side of the
planet
for how far you're gonna be able to see
what the weather effects are gonna be
like
the sound effects i don't know if you
guys listen to those as well
um just didn't know how much of you guys
got into that you're looking forward to
seeing these weather and snow effects
like the one little tiny one in one of
the
europa trailer um there's a point where
he scans of like that thermal scope and
you see enemies that you would not
otherwise be able to see and i was just
wondering i was like
that actually might be a thing if you
have stuff to do where the weather's
actually happening
that could be a big deal so i wonder
what you guys thought about the weather
if you're like excited to see a
long time coming don't have too high
hopes what do you guys think
you think man uh i'm excited i
i it makes me as the question are they
going to add something to that
to existing worlds or maybe it's just
going forward are they gonna you know
now build that into new destinations i
i think that's awesome and what a cool
idea that you know so
a snowstorm can blind you and you have
to
you know either it's a weapon or it's a
you know a ghost or whatever whatever
thing is going to you know
activate that that thermal scan or
whatever
they're going to call it you know i
think that's such a cool added layer
to how we're going to go through a new
world
yeah absolutely yeah i'm with you man i
mean for me it's one of those things
where i just
love when they add new systems or
a new tech and it seems like that this
is a part of that
with bungie with uh beyond like so you
know
just to see how the weather changing and
these systems now being added to destiny
you know it's pretty cool you know i'm
saying we we're seeing the game evolve
and seeing how that affects
you know visibility and how we deal with
characters and stuff like that
and i can't wait to see the
implementation you know i'm saying i i
i love the idea of a weather system in
destiny so
um yeah this stuff is pretty cool man
i'm just excited that
whether it's due to the destiny content
vault or you know this
upgrading or fixing of the engine you
know that we get a chance to
implement new things they've been
experimenting obviously we had the um
yeah crashed in you know so i i like to
see even if they're in a small level
newer things being implemented it's
pretty ambitious so
as a techie i love this stuff so this is
this is kind of cool for me what you
thinking
yeah i mean i'm too like the sound alone
if you sit there and listen to what like
the sound of like
oh it's like a squall like the just like
the effects the audio guys man
sometimes the stuff that they come up
with is always really cool um
i feel about this so sitting there
listening to like the wind and
everything of just like what it sounds
like of that storm coming in what it's
gonna be like the
the effect that's gonna have on the game
and that's one of those where it's like
turn your audio up when you play destiny
like don't have your own soundtrack on
unless you're streaming because
the the audio in this game is always
cool but i think europa's a really
fitting one for
weather system because you have a planet
and they have the effects on the
buildings where they have like
sideways icicles from the weather and
everything's frozen so it's like feels
like it's in a constant blizzard we
actually get to
see it in action i think is really cool
as opposed to hey this is what
happened when you weren't here as
opposed and now we actually get to be in
it like
i think that'll be cool so even if it is
more
cosmetic as opposed to you actually get
like a cold effect and you got to go
find a tunnel to hide in
i still think it's actually cool that we
get to see it um just while we play it
it'll just be cool to like you know drop
into an area that
let's say like a lost sector and you
know the sound
of like howling wind and snow just goes
away and you go into this like whatever
like
icicle dripping cave
it'll just all be really [ __ ] cool
because they they're so spot on with
their sound
and atmosphere work absolutely
yeah the unsung heroes of destiny
it the sound effects teams the
orchestras
i mean every aspect of sound in this
game
is pretty amazing weapons everything
and they just don't get enough credit
and i will continue
to beat this drama this man wants to
stand by these people bro i
want death video game awards i'm tired
of the shenanigans
destiny has to win something in sound
in some level like i'm not having it bro
like and i know people oh you're a fan
boy just because you let it get no this
i've played games this game has some of
the
best sound and the best sound effects in
gaming yeah put it this way not to cut
you out right now no no no
the damn trailer for damn festival that
we gonna get into i'm sitting there like
oh
okay like come on rocky like how
is this game not winning anything
in musical categories sound cat it
drives
me nuts continue rant over
no i i definitely i definitely get that
like
a thousand times over it's uh
like the amount of sounds that go into
just a weapon is like 20 different
sounds for
you know talk about it for xenophage to
shoot
oh man i bought it it was like 20
different sounds and they're most of
them are handmade
bro or if not all of them are handmade
it's like
yo you like you handmade the way a gun
shoots and people don't you know think
about that people just think you know
i'll get a gunshot sound and like add
other things around it but like
they're making this thing sound
like organic and feel alive
just the distinctness also last point
number one it's just like i
it's so good that you don't even have to
see and sometimes you if you're with
someone
in a fire team let's say you're playing
with some blueberries right and you're
in a fire team about to do a strike
you don't know what's going on but you
can hear you're like oh this guy's using
like this gun you can hear based on the
sound
the distinct nuances of each gun you can
now identify what someone is using as a
weapon
and i think that's just so so cool getty
you're about to say that
yeah no i mean that's that's all of it
is like there's certain guns even just
the first time in destiny 2 i picked up
just not a rifle like skate lock i'm
like
that's one that always sticks out for me
and it was just a basic auto rifle but
as i picked it up and i started i was
like
this is how this gun should sound like
it fit really well and they nailed that
for so many different things when you
feel like an amalan
you know like hung jury back in d1 was
like an epic one but that had its own
distinct like sound to it and
it feels so they have a special sound to
them and as you say when you get into
exotics like
like the trace rifles when you've got
these laser beams and you've got
you know the way the rockets like too
fire when you've got um
what is the the one that fires two
the rocket launcher yeah i can't oh no
yeah that's my giant like that one that
goes but yeah it was like when xenophage
like you hear that
like you hear how that thing sounds yes
that's amazing
the sound in this game has always been
really cool the fact that they're just
making it better
yeah always always enjoy that
what else we got e so we got the weather
earlier last
last week and then for the 12 they
talked about more of the technical side
of what they're trying to we know
stuff's going in the destiny content
vault
we also got confirmation that
uh you're gonna re-download the entire
game yes
now some people like oh is it new engine
new engine they're like no they they
kind of shut that down
they are they're always adapting and
building on the engine they're refining
things they're building new technology
the almighty live event is proof of the
fact that it's still the
game that we're still playing and with
the patch they put the ability to do
that in the game so i mean they're
always
adapting and going with it they are
working on things like they
they shifted their mission scripting to
run on the physics host instead of the
mission host so
instead of just knowing that cool yeah
it's like there have been people have
kind of broken it down but they're like
they're able to see like where things
are more what's going on as opposed to
who of this thing is alive like they get
a lot more nuance and detail
um which hopefully maybe for one
if they have that much more like live
tracking of what's going on they're able
to
maybe help with cheaters we'll have to
see um so hopefully this is a thing
cross your fingers
but also allows them to do more things
with what's actually happening
so they're working on behind the scenes
technologies and stuff like that so
from all that stuff that you guys read
about the technologies and the reinstall
and the size and
that was a very technical article i'm
not going to go read it all for you guys
here but is there anything that you guys
pulled out from that one that you're
really excited about any portions that
you liked cognito
sincere we know it for sure anything
from the tech article that like jumped
out at you
oh it's so cool i mean for me you know
one we got like you said
we got the confirmation that obviously
it's not a new engine
but it's basically you know fixing
things on the back end
first of all i had no problem when they
said
you know we got to uninstall and then
you know redownload it again because
i'm like oh you're condensing my file
size i'm already a fan
like like at that point i'm like i
already like the fact that this game is
gonna get a little bit smaller that way
just that content
you know is gonna be going into the ball
stuff but now this is cool especially
with you know the direct stuff the
mission stuff
the way things are going to be operating
on a technical level from a mixed
instructor and what was cool
is we got the explanation of
why prophecy was going away because of
the systems
are not going to they would interfere
they would not work correctly
based on the these news do a system so
that's pretty that's pretty dope
um i just love when they they lift the
veil sometimes you know
if they don't do it all the time and i
don't know if it's
because things were you know some things
were put out there in the universe that
maybe they didn't what in the universe
they wanted to clarify you know so um
look man this is cool i love to always
know about the back end of destiny how
things are interacting system wise
and i guess i love explanation so for me
technically
this is cool and i just think ultimately
it should make the game better you know
i mean so
that's what it comes down to i don't
know if you got a chance um i regard if
you got a chance to uh
see it in that technical or read any of
that technical stuff yeah i
uh i looked at it briefly but i
i think um what ebonis was saying about
how their
scripting missions and i i just
i love to see an evolution of like that
because i know a lot of people say like
oh
do this shoot things mission over like
yeah the whole game is
do that shoot things you know over like
let's be real but it's also how how it's
presented and
how it unfolds is kind of what keeps us
uh engaged and um i like that they're
updating you know kind of the
the lighting that's happening in the old
the older worlds
uh edz and
um nessus um
and i'm not too surprised that they're
not updating the
the engine i mean they're shipping this
game
out the day a new console you know comes
out
or granted bungie has probably already
had
the series x and these five you know dev
kits for
you know a year plus but i think we're
gonna see
uh what's the next one uh the the
what's the next fall queen
which queen i think i wouldn't be
surprised if they would try
to do uh a
uh kind of like an engine overhaul by
then
right because they haven't done it since
d2 has come out right um
so i i think it's a lot of work for you
know company to do a
yeah an engine overhaul i mean fortnite
just did it and
you know people think like oh there's
not a lot that goes in the back end of
fortnite
like just look at the game it's like
nope there's a there's a lot
like there's a lot uh i did a studio
tour with bungie recently and they
they talked about not i guess not
recently it was february
you know floss right there yeah
it was it was in february but they
talked about you know how
how telesto comes up all the time as far
as like
you know bucking the game and they
explained
the the design of that gun
program-wise and scripting wise is
unlike any other gun i i forget the
exactly how it kind of works it's like
you know it shoots
it shoots out other
it kind of shoots out other uh
i'm trying to think of how to phrase
this other like
other interactable
i don't want to say explosions i want to
say in a different way but like you kind
of
can kind of grasp what i'm saying or it
it's
you're spreading you know basically
things out into a game world that can
interact with other moving
objects around it so you know it's not
it that's that's built differently than
you know let's say
just ward cliff coil or like you know a
rocket that has like
delayed or has like an explosive
detonation
or whatnot a cluster bomb um it's just
made completely different that's why it
breaks so many different things because
it's
it's uh it's a unique weapon oh yeah um
and
just the way they talked about their
game they're like yeah there's just so
much that goes into
you know even just bringing trials back
like just to
just to bring that back like is not just
okay flip a switch
yep yeah i got it all you guys drink the
trials
folder back into the destiny 2.
john's name has ps5 dot savings xbox
series x like
[Laughter]
that's a legitimate thing to think about
for like telesto the way you described
it is basically it's like
you have a weapon but then it's got to
create objects that go out of the world
they have to try and some attach to
either the floor
which is going to be a certain like
piece of geometry you've got a moving
character model that's going to be
running around and so like you're
creating objects as you said you're not
just like
hit tracking like or hit scanning with a
gun to see it's like hey when i fire and
pull a trigger
is that number gonna appear there based
on where i'm aiming it's like no i'm
creating something that has
travel time that has to attach that has
to interact and
that's like that's another thing is when
they did the um
like just goes into wondering they had
um
what's the new wither horde when you put
the
like when you shoot out the wither horde
has like the death the damage over time
thing
and then people were switching to
mountaintop and changing the damage
numbers that we're ticking like
those are a couple of those things we're
like dude the game's complicated guys
like give them a break sometimes
it is absolutely like whether it's made
like
whether it's like it is spaghetti code
or not like some of those things show
how
oddly oddly made that like some of the
stuff has to be for it just to work
oh absolutely absolutely it's such so
many so many guns with
so many unique properties and how to
interact with the world and everything
like that
is again like like you know
like you were saying before it's just
like we we have to give them credit you
know say like
these are a lot of systems it's it's not
an all you gotta do
situation because i hate there's a lot
of we as gamers sometimes can tend to be
uh
armchair developers and it's just like
you know because
to us it's simple to us it's just i i i
i switch to this gun and i shoot it
you know to make that happen it takes
you know departments of people facts
facts and the fact that it doesn't break
nearly any it does it only breaks as
much as it does
right like and that doesn't happen often
when you take other games that come out
and have like oh we had a patch that
came out that fix a thousand bugs i'm
not gonna name the game but if you know
what i'm talking about you know and it's
just like
we have issues in destiny it's not
perfect but their list of like known
issues is like
seven or eight and they're usually
somewhat entrenched as opposed to
nothing works and you're like this game
barely should probably work as it is
right yeah yeah absolutely because again
it's all these different systems on top
of each other and being that they're so
creative and they're so out of the box
with a lot of these weapons and the
properties of armor and stuff like that
it's all these different systems and
they have to make sure that when they
introduce more new things
you know how these variables and stuff
interact but yeah i agree but yeah i saw
that did we get the uh the face thing
yet or we
no the fact that faces were changing up
hadn't got there that was the last piece
that
yeah so you get the fate well you get
two things with face you get the face to
face
joining where like if you're in a tower
or you're on on edzy and you're like hey
here's a person i want to join them
you are just part of their fire team now
as opposed to having to go out
reload that instance and then be with
them that's just a better system speed
for
hey there's somebody like somebody in
the tower you don't have to reload it
you just get to join them
but for you i'm going to let you take
this one yeah your face might look a
little different
yeah man so it's pretty much they said
they rebuilt the uh character face
system you know what i'm saying so
pretty much they were um
you know talking about how how they were
leveraging that tech and
you know as far as customization and
also what i like which was kind of cool
um the iowa guardian which is they were
talking about um
reviewing the existing models as far as
from uh from a diversity community
standpoint
you know trying to get more inclusion
there right so i thought that was cool
and then um yeah they just said that
when you
when you what you might notice when
beyond light starts is that we will
our guardian's face will be a different
now sadly i didn't see anything about
beards
need a beard of my guardian i need some
distinction
but but i i have to say that i'm happy
that at least
it's mentioned that the you know the
systems are being worked on and stuff
like that
i do love the diversity aspect i was
going to give it back to eat out he's
back
in reference to uh you know we love this
talk like this is cool you know saying i
want to get your [ __ ]
or the still no beards just yet
me i like i said i stay fairly clean
shave and i did no shave november once
and it was
fairly unkept like if i did that again i
would have to keep things in line but
no like somebody like eric's the dude
wants his beard come on like you put
beards in this game and people are going
to be like all right
him bro but there's a couple people like
like
bigger personalities out there it's like
give them a beard but again also you
like
you look at even just some of the nuance
of making hair
you can make kind of a general hair
texture and then you go look at like the
remastered spiderman i'm like
dude has like eyebrow eyebrow hairs
yeah like so like some of the detail
that it gets into is
it takes a little bit more than people
think now hopefully maybe that's
something they eventually get there if
they can actually
uh somebody was asking in chat if
there's gonna be ever a barber to like
redo your look
i kind of hope it's okay maybe like yeah
we're gonna
we're gonna push this piece of face over
here we're gonna pulse it like
i have no idea how they would explain
that lalore if you're just like let me
redo my face but
if i mean for an exo would totally get
it but the other two is they're kind of
like skin that'd be kind of funky but
i would still like to see it oh yeah i
forgot you could be an exo i mean i knew
that but like
can i be an xo with a beard
is it like mechanical beards like in
transformers too
don't remind me of the pain
come on man the funniest thing i
listened to recently was if you guys
know of kind of funny
what do you do all the in reviews yep
a fan of that series that they did all
the transformers and reviews
it's just hilarious the first time it's
a special place for me yeah because it's
the first yeah that was
like the way they did that the way they
brought bumblebee looks first time you
see optimus and like that one
they got out they've gotten rather out
there since then there's like some
moments there's like the one
uh it's like the three like black suvs
that turn into like
almost like the cheater running ones
it's the yeah that one's i think on
the third one i really like that chasing
because it's got the ferrari it's got
the camaro and those three it's like
i always love those just for the effects
of the scenes right but yeah when it
comes to like
it's been huge giants you don't you
those are for like oh pretty explosions
that's not
for the first one i did enjoy though but
yeah after that
two was probably the worst i will say
like two is a big fall off and three was
a little better but yeah they've been
don't get me started with michael bay
[Laughter]
douglas you go to those movies to pick
kick back look at
right right explosions and popcorn in
your face i mean those
those are popcorn flicks absolutely i
believe the homemade what's his day i
think it's
travis knight whoever did um
bumblebee if you're uh oh yeah just the
one off of him yeah
yeah that one was solid if you're a g1
fan like i'm an old-school
g1 transformers guy and that to me was
more of the essence you know saying kind
of thing but yeah i i
agree i was a beast wars kid man oh yes
yeah i thought that was so cool
look at the beast voice you already know
shout out to see my g once those g ones
up in there like that
one transformer talk that's what i'm
talking about what else we got here
but that's mostly like the background
stuff on just like when we're getting a
new
we're getting a new download things are
gonna look fresher i mean if you go
like different lighting and things so
it's like all the people everybody's
like oh new engine new engine and it was
just it was nice to see them for once
shut that down on twitter yeah
uh and two just the fact that they are
still able to do a lot within
you know the confines of their current
engine they
and that's the thing it's like you take
the shooting in destiny it is built
to feel as good as it does in this in
this system that they have like you try
and go put that in our narrow four
it's probably not going to be there or
it would take them so much work if it's
not worth it
that's a good point you've always made
that point respecting it
if you don't know how that thing yeah i
was going to say a quick run through on
the emblems i want the movie of the week
emblem because that one is fire
that's the orange one uh
that one looks really cool you got the
artist you got the fashion [ __ ]
punching down he's not bad kind of
guardian but he's like like the full
banner of the movie of the week he got
like just it almost looks like
almost like orange star trek with like
the stuff on the walls you got like the
head and like the
movie i have an idea for um
like a movie of the week that i want to
do it's just like it's gonna take me a
long time to put it together
uh then you got the mentors the ninjas
and the shields shout out to one shield
that's probably in our chat that's
definitely gonna be ares that's like the
moderators and stuff like that
the ninjas are the people who are like
um like the
forum moderators go in and like clean
stuff up and keep the comments clean and
the mentors are ones that are out there
trying to guide everybody so they're
they're trying to take care of their own
which is good
and of course it's on game pass can't
can't say that one enough that like
i mean as of was it last week on the
22nd or something like that it's like
game pass has forsaken has shadow keep
shadow key i mean in destiny 1 was art
and destiny 2 is already free so i mean
you've got
three years of content if you haven't
played in a minute you can jump in for
free
and beyond light number 10 november 10th
xbox series x boot that thing up man
yeah man get what's cool is a lot of
guardians or
people are like yo i i'm going to get
back into it man [ __ ] what's going on so
i'm like
here's my friend ivantes i've been
playing like hey
he does the content here
the comments that i get occasionally are
usually those type it's like here's the
leveling
like the guide from 750 to 1060 for this
season
i still get people hey i'm new or i
haven't played in a while thank you for
clearing this stuff up i'm like
those are the ones i'm like i always
wonder if the time that i put into some
of those are worth it and then those
comments even if it's just like one more
person coming in
and feeling comfortable to start the
game i'm like that's why those are there
so i'm like i'm happy to see that still
getting work
such a lane for you because at the end
of the day there's so many people
when they boot up destiny and they
haven't played in so long
in some viewers since d1 and they get to
that director and they get to that list
and they still don't know they're
overwhelmed they don't know where they
should start
that seems to be the consistent thing so
um yeah you know
it's going to be a lot of kindergartens
coming through in the xbox ecosystem
with gameplan man
yeah man we got gotta help them out
because they are interested they
are touching on shadow keep forsaken now
and like i said with um
beyond light it's going to be even crazy
to have that you know with the launch of
the series x as well so
get get ready i'm sending them
hey it's like i got to get my video
together i got well i just got to get my
feet wet to know it's like i have an
idea we're going to go up to like 1260
power level or whatever that
12 60 12 10. i can't remember to have to
go look at some of the infusion stuff
but
like i mean we know we're gonna go up in
a power level but we don't know
there's so much we don't know i was
actually on the filler last night with
like it was another podcast we were just
talking about like the state of destiny
and how for one how many people are
playing it right now most of the podcast
wasn't which was interesting
because we are in this low right now but
also it's like we've said this on this
podcast and i brought it up there it's
like
we're six years into this franchise if
some of the stuff is running a little
long in the tooth i mean you see people
like
preparing like currencies and like
stocking up on bounties and
they said they were going to try and
change the leveling system we're six
weeks out and we don't have a clue what
that's going to be like
right still plenty of time it's like
there's a lot
no there it is tell them james tell them
and it's like and i know they're going
to trickle that stuff out but it's like
you know i would like to see them when
it comes to the raid race like when you
re-download the game and you log into
beyond light
you don't have like 50 bounties stocked
up from iron banner and other things i
want them to like
clean slate this stuff but that means
they also need to tell people fairly
soon on some of those things
whether it's like hey if they're going
to give us like different quests and
strikes and storyline and things are
going to function a different way like
we can jump and know that but
the the preparation that a lot of people
do i'm probably not going to just
because i'd much rather
take my time and enjoy what's there but
either way it's like that type of stuff
we need some people are gonna be really
pissed if you're like oh by the way
we're going operation clean sweep on
your bounties
yeah i think i don't i can't imagine
that they
they see people like horde bounties and
engrams
and they'd be like yeah that's what we
wanted like that's what i'm saying
it's gotta be a system issue you know
it's
i and that's just people like taking
advantage of the
the way the system is and
you know it's up to bungie to the ch to
change and
they don't they can't predict you know
how people are going to take advantage
of the system and you know
you know do like maximize it
it's never in a prediction um
i agree but uh i like that they're
changing it up
no i agree to each point shout out to uh
kevin in the chat too like
you know i i've doubt i've never been a
fan like the new content comes out
you know and no disrespect to any
content creator look if you know the
system and you know how to beat it i
i dudes are gonna do what they're gonna
do right but at the end of the day it's
like to be
just like so sacrilegious to sit there
and be like oh okay
let me get all these bounties and i have
like 30 bottles for the new content and
then you literally
launch the day one and new content click
click and you like click click click
click click click all right i'm at max
level that's i'm like
you know me like i gotta i actually
that's what i turned very pro developer
and i'm just like
that has to suck for them like they they
cannot be
like you said iron garden in their
mentality that this is how they want
the new experience to be played and
these guys you know guys are out there
so
you know hopefully like you said with
maybe with the new systems and
and stuff like that you know like i said
kevin made a good point you know if they
deleted all your bounties
you know in your inventory i don't have
a problem with that you know what i'm
saying like i want
i think sometimes as you know we have
that format we want you want to be at
the top and
stuff like that so quick but it's just
like you know
look at people say i've done the offense
i've never done that but the reality is
just like
you know we just want the game to be
experienced
you know the right way yeah i i
even kind of missed like grinding gears
uh
uh grinding guns a little bit yeah yeah
yeah our last guess we were talking
about that too like he was talking about
like a weapon mastery but yeah it's like
you used to have to
level up your weapon you'd spend some
time with it yeah unlock the perks
and the in i don't know if there's
there's there's something long and hard
about that but there's also
something yeah just have at it have at
it guys
it was so funny but it was so
funny i was like i gotta rock it that
way i got a little bit right i realized
what i said i was like i'm just gonna
keep going
as soon
there's something grindy about it but
it also just adds like a different
experience like you can't you can't
hoard
anything in that process you know if
it's not
tied to a material or maybe like the
materials tied to in a certain way that
you can't
you know grind it out and farm it
yeah i feel like farming is a thing
that's just inherent with rpgs
or you know uh mm mmorpgs
and that'll never you know not go away
but
uh i think bungie's in a special place
with their game
to like reinvent things because
no one's doing it like they do it like
marvel's avengers is probably the only
game that's similar to it uh currently
i i know the division and uh anthem
for those for those fans out there but
so long we knew thee i know yeah
whenever that comes back
i'm pulling for it i'll pull it for
next-gen
refresh next-gen anthem 2.0 well at
least i'll make your playstation
fly away yeah that thing like anthem was
lit uh anthem was not optimized much at
all it was either trying too much with
the hardware that was available but even
it was it's i've been so spoiled by
destiny's port
to pc that it like you turned it on and
i was like
butter smooth yeah
i was like and you play other games
you're like hey how's this play on p
like playstation 4 it's like
they all have their quirks because like
man destiny has run smooth for so and
that's the thing is like when i keep
saying
it's like destiny should there's
probably so many things on a technical
level when they're like
please let it work and it's like and it
runs as smooth as it does
most of the time that's always kind of
what's impressive
it's it's definitely a fantastic port
but yeah it's like the system
piece as you're saying is like while it
runs good if we're getting tired of the
same stuff like that's why we're hoping
if this is like a soft destiny 3 with
the
um i can't even think what the hell's
the expansion coming oh beyond light
yeah beyond light
yeah beyond light big giant brain fart
there uh
if that's like a soft destiny 3 i think
we're still kind of hopeful as we do
have six weeks that there are some
substantial changes coming with this one
hopefully
what's not getting substantial changes
is festival of the lost
yeah yeah so ava's back the masks are
back
the haunted forest is back
we know all of those are returning um
which in and of itself isn't bad and
honestly i didn't expect anything
different
because festival lost as it's still in
the season we got the delay
i didn't expect this to be a brand new
festival now the fact that this was
supposed to launch
during yeah beyond light begs the
question
of were you still going to be able to
boot this up from the tower or the
director and just go into the infinite
force like the infinite forest would
still be in the game hidden somewhere
even though mercury's leaving
technically doesn't exist yeah yeah i
was like so it's like the fact that it
got delayed
there's all big speculation as to why
but the fact that it got delayed makes
this
okay because if the infinite force was
accessible
after beyond light that would be a
little weird so
this is maybe a blessing in disguise i'm
not entirely sure we've got
candy to earn we've got the forest to go
back into
um it is gonna work a little different
you're gonna go to spider
probably kick off a quest that's gonna
take you like you know one or two runs
in the forest
and then basically you're gonna be
getting now cypher decoders
they describe them the same way you get
umbrella and grams just a lot of places
in the game where you would be seeing
legendary engrams you might also be
seeing these cipher decoders
and what those are going to do you can
hold a max of 25 at the end of your
forest run in the haunted forest there's
a chest for finishing it and there's
gonna be five chests at the end that
you're gonna be able to open
with these cypher decoders so you'll be
able to like go stock up 25 and then do
500 forest runs in a row
and those are going to be holding um
quite a few different things between
we've got the two weapons so the
braytech
uh werewolf i think it is and then i
cannot remember the other weapon
uh horror story horror story horror
story so you got two auto rifles
actually oddly but you've got those two
they're gonna have random drops they did
say if you go look them up on like
light.gg or in the api they're showing
perk combinations
that are not real because i think
something like as the cross was like
sorry everybody no double tap the
trigger or something like that
so those wouldn't stack because some of
that stuff would be a little broken they
said they might actually release like an
official
list come next week which is cool um
you're gonna have your candy you're
gonna have your masks and your bounties
and things like that
so it's going to work mostly the same we
do have a couple cosmetic things like a
shell a sparrow and a ship
they all look to be fairly mummy wrapped
which is cool
and then probably the coolest thing as
you guys said was the trailer the whole
trailer started and played and everybody
was like
i'm sorry so i was like i covered the
basics but i was like what do you guys
think about festival of the last
uh irl sir get the guardian man
uh it's my favorite event for sure uh
there's obviously things that i
uh you know i don't like about it but
overall it's definitely
the best like they overhauled the tower
they got the spooky music and the sound
effects and then just
like the vibe is like spooky season i'm
all for it and uh
i love the haunted forest and
actually it'll be interesting because
you said you know it's obviously coming
out before
beyond light it's on a location that's
going to disappear
yes so what they do with that going
forward and i i
i kind of wish they they changed the
location
this is what our third time going into
it yeah
or even if you want to say fourth
because there was like that
spring event they took us to the rivalry
and we've been in here a lot
yeah i just i i know it's like a
repeatable it's a cool idea but i
i i hoped something different about
it would would come in or like maybe
the way you go through it changes um
i'm excited to get the braytech
uh ar because i never got it the first
time around
yeah i love the the new
i do we know if it's armor or is it
cosmetics so hold on i was gonna say
i've got the list right here so you've
got
legendary gear which i would imagine
just anything and probably whatever
armor pool can drop
uh you've got the two auto rifles masks
festival shaders
those are what can come from the caches
that's what they list out there
now i will say for those of you who are
listening to this now
um and if you guys get the audio before
tuesday
if you've already got braytech werewolf
and horror story
people on twitter seem to be saying i
heard this one other place and saw it
again today as i was looking
um pull those from collections and stick
them in your vault
because potentially if the new ones are
random rolls
you're not going to be able to pull them
from collections because anything with
random you can't pull from collections
and some of these have pretty good rolls
in the first place on them like
they're pretty decent god rules for what
they are so if you have these in your
collection now
pull one of each out put them in your
vault and don't touch them because
you may be able to get different or
better you know god rolls from the
random rolls
but the ones that they come with are
solid and if you can pull them now you
should potentially be able to also use
them as well
what about the the sun setting aspect on
those old ones though like what's what
i don't know honestly like i haven't
logged into the game to check
but i know people have been saying like
literally like tassie had one up this
morning as well just saying pull them
pull these out of collection so trust me
i'll look into it this weekend i'll
probably put up a video or something as
soon as i know
but potentially with that coming um
you if the perks on those are still good
which i think both of them were decent
like i think braytech was better than
horror story
but if they have like roles that you
won't be able to get potentially get
them now and throw them in there so at
least got something good
yeah i mean you know for me yeah i i
i'm sorry air regarding like i i've
never been the greatest
yeah that's all good no disrespect
but i will say this for this particular
one
the trailer was so fire that i was like
you know what
i'm kind of into it it's just like it
was one of those things that
you know me and eve talked about we
looked at the road map we knew the delay
was coming
we see what's on the road map and i see
festival lost i'm like oh lord
we ain't gonna have a lot to do but it's
gonna be a slow
season until we all like come out but i
have to admit i mean i am
surprisingly looking forward to this i
haven't logged in in a while
so the music got me rocking you know
they got a lot of stuff i
i to your point i did wish there was
some slight change as far as the
infinite force on the ground but
to each point it does make sense because
it still hasn't gone away yet
so it kind of fits now that it's there
yeah it's like it's the last time
potentially we're going in there so
the last two are for the infinity so i
thought that was cool yeah i i
agree i thought that was cool and then
for me one of my
i thought i would never get a chance to
get horror story my horror story and my
and all that stuff break tech back
because you know when i went over from
xbox to pc i brought i started over i
didn't bring
my um much cold over because i've been
playing pc so so long at that time
so i need to get horror story back i
need
i had all that stuff so it'd be cool to
get into it shout out to scene free from
bms he said
cog you're looking forward to it until
you got to log in and play
i'll feel it i feel you brother but it's
just like
i look it it came at the perfect time
for me i've been on a little bit of a
hiatus from destiny
you know logging real quick jumping the
infinite forest scene now e did they say
why did i feel like i read they said we
were getting ornaments
we got ornaments or anything in this it
was just it's just oh you're gonna
you're gonna have armor ornaments and
those are those three sets so if you go
to the
the main page you've got the what looks
to be a frankenstein
titan yeah i'm guessing it's a feel of a
like kind of werewolfish because it's
got kind of the fur
and like the kind of wolf looking mask
on the hunter i don't know what the
cloak's gonna look like
the warlock is i like the warlock
actually because it looks like
it looks awesome eighteen hundreds like
dracula yeah yeah like it looks like
transformers dracula you got like the
little
frilly chest you got like the suit coat
you got the
look like i will say i think like the
frankenstein might look cool but i think
the warlocks just it looks clean
man i feel i mean okay no that was it
like so yeah
those are all gonna be likely the way or
those are probably gonna be eververse
ornaments what
would be my guess now i haven't seen
officially if we're going to be able to
earn them or not but my guess those are
going to be eververse ornaments for
those okay so these are all
okay well first of all yeah if that's
the that's pretty cool
um i think the hunt is shining right now
hunters yeah
that's right like i love it i've been
jealous of hunters the last
two kind of weapon ornaments and armor
sets they've been they've been out here
moving man
um well i will agree uh at first at
first
you know how i am about warlock my
warlock mask so i wasn't feeling the
mask effort but then when i saw what the
aesthetic that it was going for the
vampire look
and i'm like okay with the pristine
right here yeah
old school dapper look man he's like the
count that's the count right there you
know what i'm saying so i'm like okay i
can get my little you know by dracula on
uh
e i gotta talk we gotta have a we have
to talk man
i have a talk um this is now two events
probably in a row
where the titan i don't know what's
going on
i mean it's like you got the chains you
got like it literally looks like pieces
on her armor like hodgepodge like welded
together it's
frankenstein is what it is is my guess
but it's i kind of dig it
i was like it it could be cool but like
from what i'm seeing i think the other
two are better i would say it would be
like you know he got the bronze medal of
anything
yeah oh clearly clearly it's we get to
that
what was that other event and
the the titan was so bad oh that was in
the season that was the seasonal armor
where he had like uh like the face
looked weird and he had like the
homeless coat and all that stuff yeah i
know
lately titans they've been hitting it
with i don't know what's going on with
the rt
with titans lately but i just i was just
like damn like
you know well i'm like all right let's
see what the titan do it i'm just like
okay
zombified titan okay like
i just did it but i just thought it was
funny i just don't want to bring it up
but now i mean look
you know spooky season have a little fun
knock this out we go and do a couple
runs in the
in the infinite forest and uh you know
just just take it for what it is but i
i'm
i'm more excited than i thought i would
be when this was announced
looks like there's going to be some cool
emotes maybe with this one you got the
rocking with the guitar and stuff they
said there's a
one inch punch finisher that one will be
silver only
so they did say that oh yeah
completely
so yeah that one will potentially be
just that i think that's the only thing
that's silver only so some will be
bright dust some will be silver and
that's why i guess where the ornaments
probably fall
uh i think between the bounties and the
candy and stuff like that is probably
from eva levante where we're gonna get
the shell the ship and the sparrow
so at least they're kind of getting
better at like those cosmetic usable
in-game things being more earnable
but as for armor ornaments yeah they
still gotta probably make you pay for
those in one way or the other
still gonna be 750 power level you can
go private or you can go
like matchmade which is always good
other than that
yeah it's pretty close to last year for
your masks you've got the traveler and
then a mummified traveler
yeah you've got varrix which actually
looks probably one of the coolest you
got the stranger anna bray
uh there's going to be probably some
sister videos in that one and you've
also got the bubbling mask which is like
your head is a
cauldron and then it looks like it's
like the green
witch's brew is like barely barely
tipping over the top it looks kind of
interesting so
yeah i gotta be honest i was never a fan
of the masks
yeah and that's like a that's like way
back to like do you want i just
i like the way i look i i'd rather have
like a
an effect go over me i just don't want
to put on a mask and like
you know go into this thing i mean i
guess it's like not that big of a deal
but it you know
to me it's like it's kind of the low
point of the halloween event
i was like i also wish there were more
ornaments or at least an optional
ornament because
like if i just want to change my look
because i'm not going to use the
masqueraders
helmet because it's like 750 power level
or whatever or it's like it's trash
power level i think anyway so it's like
the mask is
never going to function the way other
stuff does so it's like the masks if you
get them all would be cool to have his
arm ornaments at least for a helm yeah
you know
for the collectors out there like people
people definitely
people definitely like to just collect
them all and you know
uh i know i kind of
like you said you the you know the event
is similar to last year
it i i wish they just took like another
step further
okay i wish you know there is there was
just something else that like
like why not give us like a new ar yeah
all
right
yeah this is like the last two i'm with
you trust me it's like i said this a
while ago as soon as we saw that this
was coming though and i was like oh this
can be the same
is it gonna be this is the this is the
copy
buff up that copy and paste like this is
literally the drag drop
yeah because i mean
[Music]
it's like was it like a halloween event
2019 double click edit 20
20.
you know tiger engine 3.0 update save
no it's not that so if developers you're
hearing this so we're giving you our
currency
everybody forgive us but i said
would you rather see them like put more
effort into this or keep like
make this what it's probably going to be
and just keep working on beyond line i'm
like beyond lights where it's at so it's
fine no
i will say it's talking about which is
room as a sword
i would even take a scythe as a sword
too
like just more things like it could just
be like an ornament like you know you
could put you can easily make an
ornament for
you know a sword uh as far as it look
i guess i would it would change the
shape of it as far as like hitbox but
yeah tangent tangent yeah i don't know
if you're on it man i mean i just think
the last part i'll say just that
again just like with iron banner rolls
around for the 35th time
you know and you're like this is going
this hasn't been here for you
and i'm going to be nice because we know
all the resources are towards beyond
lights i'm going to be nice
but it is kind of
it's it's kind of a joke that we're
getting horror story
and you know breakthrough get no new
weapon no different you know what i'm
saying kind of thing
because if you add that and you add that
incentive and it's a new weapon and it's
cool and it's themed in
a halloween kind of way you really drive
up the engagement you really drive up
the chase you want people to get yo i
got to get that
you know some kind of thing for for this
to be the same i only benefit because i
missed out
but for you guys you've got all this
like yeah you know what i said it would
have been awesome
you you know what's a great spot for
this event
the menagerie okay yeah
go read it on that place you know it's
also a great spot for this event
what is it the the part
after the bridge in the [ __ ] oh the
record
the reckoning i like your mono i like
your idea
of bringing back the menagerie in a
festival of the lost kind of way and
this way you get the six player
pseudo raid engagement but not as hard
right yep and it's
themed towards i'm with you all now i i
i like that you wanted something i was
like it's probably a bigger environment
for them to like
rebuild to like make it because like
the work they do in the tower i was like
i agree the the tower has probably one
of the coolest looks because it's got
the
the festival kind of halloween
celebration still got the spooky vibes
to it like they nailed the look in the
tower
and like yeah they make it like
nighttime and dark and shadowy in the
infinite forest
like candles around yeah yeah that's
great always cool but i was like i
wonder how much work that would be to um
rework the menagerie to really give it
the quality look
that we'd want i already got the vibe
though like you put that giant
that's what i said yeah that's why i
said it you know it's already like dark
and like
green and you know spooky all you got to
do is like you know throw some music
over it and
have the egyptian the um objectives like
you know different and i even forgot it
was six player because most of the
seasonal events are only three player
but you know you all put it on a place
for the director
we'll see yeah you make it like a spooky
castle like a spooky callous castle you
know what i'm saying like
i got the vision you know there's six
guardians got to go in there and then
you know you just go through you got
your rewards at the end or whatever
if there was some way they could remake
it because we let me we admit like
that's one of the
the ones that we're going to miss right
where minaj is going to go away
in the in the content for that that's
something if it could be come back
reimagined in some way
that would be i mean if eric's is coming
back then you know
a version of prison of elders is there
you go
you know going to come back because the
reef is still going to be on the
director
yep um so maybe he could say yeah
fuse mines my my one
big win of this thing though yes i want
that freaking emblem it's so good
oh yeah yeah it looks amazing
like the like the kind of haunted skulls
sitting on the pyramid the like the
planets and the pyramids with the dark
i don't know if i'm going to take that
thing off all year long that emblem is
amazing like it fits beyond light that
was probably my most excited
that was the one thing i tweeted out but
i was like yeah the wrapped ghost like
they look cool they're thematic and
stuff but i'm like no that emblem
i don't usually don't care about emblems
and the first time i was like nope they
nailed that one it's mine
that was that was the one
uh but that's most of it for uh the
haunted forest and uh festival lost if
you haven't watched the trailer if
nothing else
that trailer will hype you up enough to
play for at least the one day you need
to probably get the stuff because that
rock music
they nailed it um i love how they use
all the different rock
e-bolts and simulate it like you know
like it's a concert girl know what those
i love that i love the energy of that
trailer yeah
final thing they did talk about was
direct relief uh they're back at it
again
bungie foundation is supporting direct
relief to provide
mass medicine resources to agencies and
now they're also helping with the um
wildfire affected communities across
california oregon and washington so
they've got the empathetic ghost shell
pin
that one's up you'll get an emblem for
getting it so it's everything all the
profits from the
october 1st which was yesterday through
the 15th
you'll be able to get the emblem and get
the pin
and it's usually basically all profits
from that go directly to
helping that cause so of course bungie
always doing amazing things and that's
one thing too it's like bungie's made
i was talking about this on the podcast
we're like my australian wildfire shirt
right now actually
i thought about that one this morning
too i was going through my like destiny
shirts because i have way too damn many
anyway and i was like
wildfire and then i saw this one i was
like nah i gotta go to the shacks the
art one i love this one
yes but yeah it's like bungee is done
i will say like and i was talking to him
yesterday we said like the game's six
years old we're hoping for kind of a
destiny three with refresh and all these
things but i will say like
bungie did two things one bungie is an
amazing
like company in itself and we've seen
like their stand up for like
the rights that they fought for like
this year especially
the work that they do the foundation and
all those things have been amazing and
then the other thing is
it is the community that they made in
this game has been
they couldn't have like intentionally
tried to make this community
but that now that it's there it's like
nothing else and those
two i will say is like while i make like
yesterday i felt like we were down on
the game for about two hours in the
podcast i was talking about because
we're talking about like
where we're at right now why we're not
playing what are all the things we want
worked on
but in the end like i'm sitting there
with six really cool people on that
podcast sitting here with
all all of you guys this morning in chat
talking you with irl like
the community of this game has been the
most amazing part of it and i just
wanted to shout that out again
yeah best community i mean agreed just
by far i mean all the friendships
and people we come across and you know
also people obviously like irl guardian
all the people we've had and just even
you know once you know covet is
under control and we're able to go back
you know into conventions again you know
we go to a gcx the old guardian cons and
all that stuff
so cool to just meet people who share
this passion for this game we love it
and the things that are created as a
result
of this passion the art community the
lore community it's just so many
you know i'm saying different community
and we got iran guardian out here
doing these you know cool studs
you know say how the hunter's supposed
to look and he's doing the finishes and
i'm like oh
man it's so cool to see all the things
that
are birthed because of the destiny
yeah so hard agreed
so yeah if you want to help support that
one you get a cool pin you get a cool
emblem always cool stuff that they're
doing so
check that one out that one's in the
bungee store we'll be there for a couple
weeks
and that's pretty much it um we are i
was gonna shout out to all you guys as
well
we are five weeks out from
um like when next reset happens we'll be
five weeks out
if you need the worldline zero catalyst
it takes five weeks to finish
weeks if you're gonna do it the slow
method for
outbreak that one also can take five
weeks as well
so depending on your progress on either
of those two specific there's some lower
bucks you can't get anymore
but like the five week window that's
like one of the last major time
milestones as things are about to leave
to keep an eye out for so world line
zero outbreak perfected
you're working on the catalyst working
on those weapons
your time is getting to the point where
you're gonna start to not be able to
actually get those done so just wanted
to give that as a public service
announcement as well
uh you have something to address in the
chat
hey it's i told him not to push it i can
do those all day
i'm over here i feel like i almost feel
like i have to wait for i or
a guardian to leave because um because
like this happens judgment
i don't judge yes
on your form this guy could probably do
like
one arm push-ups or pull-ups and i'm
over here like
yeah anyway you guys can talk it out to
wrap this thing up and then i will be
back because i never know what said when
i'm gone which is always a worry because
i don't listen through the whole thing
yo shout out to new rap for being messy
he got his points he said i gotta make e
do these sit ups
you see we he respected the elbow though
e so as we hear hit the last word at the
campfire ira garden yeah
i said we like to promote fitness man we
like to look it's covered 19 out here
you're indoors but you could still do
things you got my man he bounces to
cheetah out here
look look at that form i regard what are
we feeling about the elbows hitting the
knee like
what are we feeling he's got to do 10
right now yeah he's doing 10 right now
he's going back to the camera going
like do you alternating or you do it
need to pull over
[Applause]
can i have you like you know comments on
my workouts
i do commentary for workouts and
apparently there's more
and they're off so it looks like who put
it in the redeem make okay
we got some more going on look man yeah
i'm interested look at the phone look
at that low to the ground you know what
i'm saying we're getting that form
everything is tight as the grass is it's
we're moving out here man we're moving
out here we got to get you in shape
it's the winter time you're indoors some
of y'all can't go to this gym but
this is a service that the last word
provides man look at look
look at them holding the horse there
isn't that kind of like a horse stance
almost like a little kind of going on
right now look at the bounce
this is it man this is what this is the
type of things that e
in the last word provided we really
trying to move
just like that you're back in the studio
look at that man look at that look at
that look at that cardio look at how
quickly he was able to get right back in
the form and just continue with the
podcast man
it's great stuff
just to give you variety where you gonna
get this high quality entertainment at
room y'all
[Laughter]
it's with the last word i kind of regret
putting those in my twitch
points thing i'll be honest
but also it's kind of fun because you
have way too much fun with it so oh i do
have a ball
you you got to see what they wait to the
last minute they like get them
every time too i'm like oh so we're
about to sort of
salute to the chat man but yeah it's
it's it's really cool
to be back back to our shenanigans yeah
i
regard he's pretty awesome too
kevin no no no no be nice y'all show's
ending
yeah we wrapping up you you guys
got your rocks off now behave
stretch them out y'all stretch them out
gonna give you give you guys some stuff
today
what's up part five how you doing what's
going on i'm sure
uh your body fat percentage is somewhere
in like
10 12 over there but we we all try and
get to your status eventually
i'm working my covent belly off so i'm
right with you
hey we're all we're we're all in some
stage of what we want to be
you're probably where you want to be
most of the time i'd imagine yourself
ah you know spooky season comes with
like a lot of treats and
pumpkin spice lattes oh
i appreciate the kind words man
absolutely
so uh were you guys doing like what did
you guys do while i was gone outros and
stuff
no no we about to do them now literally
wait no i saved the outros for you
yeah so i mean irl guardian um
james senor awesome in life guardian
uh like thank you man it's been an
absolute pleasure to have you on
we could talk movies and stunts and
for like getting into this time any day
man yeah we got to bring a boy back we
spent the first half just talking about
movies
like i could do that like the whole time
so i was like no it's like my love of
movies is way too big so
the fact that you like work in the
industry and then you're talking about
stuff and i'm like hey how about tom
cruise you're like oh dude he's a beast
i'm like oh man like
oh just like so many cool things so but
that this time
it's yours so tell them where to find
you how to support you where to look for
you if you got any upcoming movies you
can't talk about
tell them where to let you know whatever
you can and you want the platform is
yours man we just we just want to make
more people know that you're
you're an awesome guy don't worry about
those nda's either
oh in that case he's like i need you to
censor the entire thing
yeah my audio just cuts out and you
don't hear from me ever
yeah you can find me on twitter irl
underscore guardian
on instagram irl guardian um
on youtube irl guardian and
today i just released a new video that i
haven't done so
in quite some time uh hoping to try to
find some time get back to it but
uh sometimes life rearranges your
priorities
and that's what i've been doing um
and yeah nice nice the legendary irl
guardian
at the campfire man absolute pleasure
brother absolute presence stories
again we could have made it a movie cast
for the first hour
it just kept on going and just loving to
see what you're doing
you know as far as stunt community as
far as just you know
everything man you you got your hands in
everything and it's really cool to see
your growth and
definitely love supporting you and love
your passion for the for destiny too so
very very cool guest
thank you so much for having me this
guy's uh has been honestly awesome
you guys are super rad to talk to and
we could have made this a movie podcast
easily easily
easily it just makes it that much more
fun so if we got that yeah that much to
talk about it's like oh you what do you
oh you like movies oh you have a wall of
movies oh okay yeah we're good
just not going to stop you're very good
absolutely uh well um cognito sir what
do you got coming
you're back from all your travels and uh
everything out there in the world so
what do you got coming up man
yeah i mean uh first of all i guess
again shout out to ira i was dope um
good to be back podcast with you you
know we've been a minute so we missed a
week or whatever
yep so uh yeah it's just good and then
obviously you know on with me
just back for vacation and then this
week obviously you know shout out to
everyone who sent some uh wishes and
stuff to mom we just you know
checking on her making sure it's okay
i'm just gonna head out there check it
out again
but um doing podcasts and gaming has
actually been
a good distraction you know what i'm
saying a positive thing to get my mind
going
off any of the negativity or that type
of stuff so um yeah man this sunday you
already know
ilp will be returning no special guest
just back with the lords man just back
with the lords talking about what's
going on in the gaming industry that
will be sunday
11 a.m eastern on the iron lord podcast
youtube channel and twitch channels
so come check us out we will be there
and
um i believe um yeah we got we got some
stuff to talk about we'll try to talk
about some um
save data stuff and next gen stuff or
we'll get that going
and then i believe uh king david will be
dropping a new king of statues of
into the statue community into marvel
and dc
these high priced figures that king
always has it doesn't fantastic please
check that out and also last but not
least
please thank you for the support lords
of gaming.net man
really been in man i'm so proud of these
guys what a tremendous team
this is the website floyd2gaming.net
y'all check it out
please go there i love the support um
one of our riders actually got
picked up by a bigger entity and uh he's
uh moving on so we kind of like the
we almost like the the collegiate level
before the stepping stone you're like
don't
leave this collegiate level bro so what
about one of our boys made it to the
majors man we already been up
dude we only been in existence for a
year and uh shout out to jared rage
virus he's been killing it with the guys
killing it for us
and he got a legit job so salute to him
i said don't get too hollywood on us
you know i'll say don't forget us so he
gave him everything he's got to do a
freelance for you every now and then now
do a little freelance for us usa show
some love that you know but absolute
you know lord2gaming.net you know by the
gamers for the gamers
amazing community a lot of good opinion
pieces and editorials check that out
and um yeah man and of course you know
it's good to be doing that last word
again you know
saying that one of the most underrated
podcasts destiny podcast if i must say
so myself
well i appreciate i appreciate y'all
many chat it's always good to see you
guys
it it's amazing i have so much fun doing
the show with you it was it felt good
to be back so so yeah it felt weird
being off last week i'll be honest man
it was just like
stuff like the weather cheating on you i
wasn't supposed to
yeah oh yeah you were you were doing
other stuff you were up hanging out with
like
much bigger fancier people than me so
now cheers
our relationship don't change
i feel hurt man i've been cheated on we
need to talk
you're out there with cole eastwood
what's going on yeah i know i was like
big name boys i was like man my schmuck
butt down here is just like
cheat is always love brother you always
you know how we do
how we do now but for both of you guys
seriously first guys for cognito send
all the love
to family to his mom seriously like
anything on family comes first so i'm
just happy he's able to jump in this
morning
and thank you guys all for being chat
having fun in here chatting up with us
i know this one was like half a movie
podcast but every so often we gotta
break uh
break the mold here and with irl
couldn't have been a better one with man
this guy doing stunts and all the info
love to get some behind the scenes some
inside baseball and stuff like that is
always cool to get
uh for me you guys know what's going on
um
for what's coming up i know october is
going to be somewhat quiet november is
going to be insane
uh with all the games coming between
godfall demon souls spider-man
which looks glorious by the way with the
new remaster
and then of course beyond light so
somewhere in there there's about five
games i want to play and you guys will
probably see me streaming and if i'm not
streaming and making a video i'm
probably offline making a video or
sleeping i'm not gonna do much else
during that time so you guys know where
to find me
in the interim i'm still trying to
decide what i want to there's like
enough time for me to probably knock out
one more game i'm trying to figure out
what i want to kind of
fill the space in whether it be like
horizon or death straining
kind of one big one would be fun uh but
other than that it's twitch twitter
youtube it's ibontes everywhere but the
big one is irl
sir james thank you very much for coming
man it's been an absolute honor to get
you on here so and it was a blast
talking to you because
obviously we felt like we had to move on
it's always a good thing when you have
to
have to stop talking because that just
means you're having too much fun
yeah thanks for having me guys this has
been a blast for sure
well uh for today guys thank you guys
chat i'm going to send you guys over to
uh
lulu she's an awesome destiny she's
working on this morning
quite a few things oh he got kicked he's
back yeah you were frozen
i got my one i got it right here at the
tail end i always have to get one drop
apparently so uh i get my one little
frame hiccup like the internet goes like
so i'm back so we'll try this again but
i'm going to send you guys over to i
lulu she's awesome she's a destiny
streamer so we're going to go say hello
to her after this so
don't leave chat so we can go send the
destiny community some love but for
episode 122 it's october
2nd guys we are sip gonna be just about
five weeks away from beyond light so
start counting down the days
get that vacation in there and for this
episode it has been
the last word